looking for the oddball discovery of the  year  try my ramaa fermions their particles  the theoretical physicists describe 75  years ago experimenters have been  looking for them ever since this year  researchers in the Netherlands finally  found them  these Meyer on a fermions aren't  fundamental particles the way electrons  and photons are their quasi particles  big groups of electrons that  collectively behave like fundamental  particles in this case some of that  behavior is downright weird for example  my honor fermions can be their own  antimatter and annihilate themselves on  a more practical level my Arana fermions  should make stable qubits the bits at  the heart of quantum computing if so  they might someday be a key component of  super powerful quantum computers  researchers are already racing to try  that for now though the discovery of  this peculiar type of matter is already  a solid runner up for our breakthrough  of the year  you